cancer is in constant combat with the
body hostile cells can trigger an
intricate network of interactions
alerting the immune system but many
cancer cells fly under the radar now
advanced sequencing techniques are
helping researchers unravel these
complex interactions with the potential
to boost the immune system and provide
life-saving treatments the cancer cells
have mutations that cause them to
relentlessly divide but these mutations
can be different between patients and
even between neighboring cancer cells
and not all mutations are created equal
to come up with treatments researchers
first need to know which mutations will
sound their immune systems alarm cancer
cell mutations can lead to abnormal
proteins in cells proteins are
constantly broken up into peptides
foreign peptides can only be spotted if
they're displayed on the surface of a
cell the immune system uses major
histocompatibility complex or MHC
molecules to bind to the peptides and
carry them to the cell surface but MHC
is vary a lot between patients and can't
always bind to the mutant peptides
mutant peptides that can trigger an
immune response and are specific to the
tumor are called neo antigens and to
find out which mutations lead to new
your antigens researchers can use
sequencing comparing the DNA from cancer
cells with healthy cells shows which
mutations the cancer has
and sequencing RNA can then show which
abnormal proteins might be produced
sequencing can also reveal what that MHC
molecules will look like and together
with the mutant protein sequences this
can predict which new antigens cells
will display but this is only half the
story because even when the antigen MHC
complexes are produced the immune system
might still miss them and fail to
respond to the threat t-cells are the
body's way of spotting foreign molecules
only t-cells with the right receptors
will be able to spot a cancers near
antigens and there are vast numbers of
different receptors understanding all
this variation is also important for
providing treatments researchers can
sequence the t-cells that have
infiltrated a tumor because t-cells vary
so much each has to be sequenced
individually using cutting-edge
techniques this can reveal whether any
have the right receptors and looking at
which genes are active can show which
cells are fit enough to attack the
intention between T cells new antigens
and MHC s is one of the most complex in
biology but quicker and cheaper
sequencing is helping researchers
understand this interaction and put
together the pieces of this complex
puzzle and this information is already
helping tailor treatments to patients
own unique immune systems vaccines put
the body on high alert for threat so a
cancer vaccine could boost the
concentration of the tumors near
antigens switching on the immune system
and flooding a tumor with the right
t-cells can ramp up the immune systems
fight against a tumor with treatments
like these researchers are hoping to
help the body win more of its battles
against cancer
[Music]
you